French I think I know what you're here
to say I've been spending a lot of time
with Beyonce and this is not a review of
having a pet it's a review of putting a
pet to sleep that is what I was going to
say I feel like you're falling for this
lizard and forgetting what you have it
for no come on grant I'm not capable of
falling for anything except review now
having said that I will not be
euthanizing Beyonce Sarris no this is no
regular dinosaur lizard grant he just
returned from the brink of death does
that sound familiar that happened to you
and me too right you relate to him don't
you
I've gotten to know him and he's
actually extremely intelligent I mean
it's like there's a lot going on up
there so he would be a crime which is
why I have purchased another pet for the
express purpose of keeping for a couple
of days and then killing I'm going to
kill that one instead
I named him Dion say tickly there you go
Beyonce and Beyonce friends for one or
two days tops and then that one I'm
gonna kill that sounds fine good yeah
since any animal at all would do for
this assignment I felt I'd found a good
way to spare the life of a creature with
whom I had perhaps developed some kind
of mutual respect but there was a
terrible flaw in my plan the picture is
good but I wish it could with more old
time you know how old-timey paper was
all yellow and yes just like that
oh that's perfect whoa where's Beyonce
doesn't that Beyonce no this is my new
closer Dion say whoa where is Beyonce
where did you put them in there together
yeah why you shouldn't put two bearded
dragons in the same tank why not
is that Beyonce's foot oh okay Oh what
happened yeah sometimes they eat each
other crazy what are you talking about
is videos
are you talking about it at Blizzard
heed each other
did you tell me that someone had a
Bolton the same thing what an AC who
looked well
I deal with grief alone maybe he's in
the cave okay alright okay
I had no emotional attachment to Beyonce
and was not sad for myself but the
injustice of what had happened troubled
me I'm so sorry
awesome after a period of reflection I
decided that I had bonded enough with
fiancee to have a genuine experience of
putting him to sleep they're coming with
me you piece of
my experience of putting Deon sage
asleep was frankly more like pet capital
punishment it was justice regretable but
completely necessary
[Music]